about 4 17 a.m local time Monday 6th of
February
the security camera in a driveway in
Civic Southeast turkey captures the
rumble
and the power going out
while in another city two hours or so
further east the earthquake sounds like
gunfire
in gazian tip nurses rushed into the
neonatal Ward to stop the baby's
incubators falling over
Witnesses say the sway and role of the
earth lasted two minutes but felt like a
lifetime
and as buildings topple crowds rush out
onto the streets
to save themselves and Survey the damage
they're confronted with chaos
[Applause]
the magnitude 7.8 Tremor was one of the
largest ever recorded in Turkey
it was shallow and powerful and felt as
far away as Greenland
foreign
Syria the rescues began immediately
under Torchlight and in difficult
conditions
people digging desperately through the
rubble with their bare hands
engender Us in Northern Syria Rescuers
from the white helmet group pulled out a
young baby who'd been cradled in the
arms of her dead elder sister
and his first light broke the scale of
the disaster became clear